hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
learn about j meter in this j meter
complete tutorial we will be learning
everything related to jmeter starting
from its installation but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
daily updates on multiple technologies
so if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel and don't forget
to hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn now without
further ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's session
so as discussed we will start with j
meter installation then we will get into
the performance testing followed by that
we will learn the j meter load testing
advancing ahead we will dive deep into j
meter api testing and finally we will
wind up the j meter tutorial for
beginners with the last topic that is
the j meter strip recording i hope i
made myself clear with the agenda now
over to our training experts let's get
started with what is jmeter
j meter or apache j meter is an open
source software which is a 100 pure java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance performance testing means
testing a web application against heavy
load multiple and concurrent user
traffic
it was originally designed for testing
web applications but has since expanded
to other test functions
to simplify let's assume that someday
your team lead tells you to perform
performance testing of some website like
google.com or facebook.com for around
100 users
what would be the first thing that comes
to your mind
do you think it's practically possible
to arrange hundred people with computers
and access to the internet and accessing
the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when a need for software like
jmeter arises
so what jmeter actually does is that it
simulates it will simulate real user
behaviors and perform load tests on a
server group of servers network or
object
moving further let's have a look at the
prerequisites to install jmeter
the only prerequisite of installing
jmeter is that java must be installed in
your system since jmeter is an entirely
based application that's why having java
installed in your system is a must
other than that jmeter can be used in
many operating systems such as linux
windows mac us or even ubuntu
now that we know the basics of jmeter
let's go on to installing jmeter onto
our system first let's check if you have
java installed in your system
for checking that we shall go to the
command prompt and type java hyphen
version
we can see that java is present in our
system here it will show the version of
java present in our system
the next step is to download jmeter
go to google chrome and type jmeter
download now go to the official apache
jmeter website and go to the binary
sections
in the binary sections we shall download
the zip folder
once the zip folder is downloaded open
the folder location then extract the zip
folder once the folder is again
extracted go inside the folder and go
inside the bin folder here the bin
folder contains the jmeter script file
for starting j meter
now it's time for us to launch jmeter
but before we launch j meter we need to
know that there are typically two types
of modes in which j meter can be
launched the gui mode and the non-gui
mode the non-gui mode may refer to two
types the first being running j meter in
the server mode and the second refers to
running j meter in the command line
and if we talk about the gui mode then
the gui mode has a limitation which
slows down the cpu utilization while
running the recorded script but
gui mode of jmeter is perfect for adding
and editing new configuration elements
thread groups and samplers as a result
of which you can view a number of
different listeners helping for
debugging here today we shall be using
the gui mode
so to open the gui mode inside this bin
folder select the jmeter.bat file double
click on this file this may take a while
and then the j meter window will open up
on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configuration
of that element are added as we see on
the test plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here the test
plan is like a place or a container
where all the elements we will use to
perform this test will be stored all the
requests listeners and everything will
be stored here
so moving forward let's rename this test
plan let's name the test plan to be
first j meter
now when you click outside this window
section you can see the element name
will change otherwise you can just save
this and also the name will change
now when this is done the next step is
to add thread groups right click on
first j meter here and select the add
option
then in this option select the threads
option and then threads group the thread
group refers to the users that are used
or created or needed to run this test so
let's name this thread group to be j
meter
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it in the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp a period in seconds
option that states the time gap between
the user's hits
third there is also a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
choose the test to run infinite number
of times
there is also scheduler here that will
help you schedule the start time and the
tests end time
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
the next step is to go to first j meter
and again to go to add in the box that
appears select samplers you can see all
types of requests that jmeter can work
on for now we will choose the simplest
of them all let's choose the http
request
here you will have to give the address
to some home pages or websites
so let's make it a little easy let's
rename it to be home pages
here in the server name or ipbox we have
to give the server name or the ip
let's pick a website let's go to the
simply learn website copy the url from
here
come back to the jmeter window and paste
it in the server name box keep in mind
we don't need to give http or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the http request
case
then in the path dialog box since we
have to access the route page we will
leave a forward slash there
now when our http test is ready we will
perform the test on it to determine what
the result of the test will be we need
to add some more test elements we shall
again right click on first j meter go to
the listener options
then in the box we can check the
different type of reports that jmeter
provides us for now we shall select two
of these
let's choose view results in table
and the view results tree
now save the test and run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
the green button here to run second you
can go to this run option and choose run
the test and the third way is you can
right click on first jmeter and choose
to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the results of the test
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be one there's just one
entry in both the results now let's try
one more thing we shall go to j meter
and change the number of threads and the
loop count
let's make the number of threads to be
around 10 and also the loop count to be
10
and now run the test
after running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed and the same happens in
the case of view results entry
since we have increased the number of
users and the loop count we can see the
test being performed accordingly
since the loop count now was 10 so for
each user the test will run 10 times
and here on the screen we can see the
time taken and the number of tests being
performed and the status of each hit
onto our website link
let's get started with what is
performance testing
so performance testing is one of the
most important phases of any product
launch as it verifies and validates the
overall product performance this testing
can be done in different forms depending
upon the resource availability and the
type and volume of the user base
the main agenda behind conducting
performance testing on any product is to
make sure that the product's performance
is as expected before it gets launched
into the market so performance testing
is the process of testing a software
application under a specific workload
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability reliability
scalability and resource usage of a
software application under a particular
workload
the main purpose of performance testing
is to identify and eliminate performance
bottlenecks in the software application
performance testing mainly focuses on
three factors of a software program
first one is the speed
here it identifies whether the response
of the application is fast or not then
comes scalability where the maximum user
load is determined and the third one is
stability where the stability of the
application is checked under various
workloads
now we know what is performance testing
let us understand why if we need
performance testing
the only concern of a software system is
not features and functionality the
response time reliability resource and
scalability are also important factors
so the goal of performance testing is
not to find bugs but to eliminate
performance glitches
performance testing is performed to help
the stakeholders with information about
the application concerning the
application speed stability and
scalability furthermore performance
testing reveals what needs to be
improved before the product goes into
the market if there is no performance
testing the software might suffer from
issues such as running slow while
several users use it simultaneously
inconsistencies across different
operating systems and poor usability
performance testing determines if the
software or application meets speed
scalability and stability requirements
under expected workloads applications
sent to market with poor performance
metrics due to non-consistent or poor
performance testing are likely to bring
a bad reputation and fail to meet the
expected sales goals
now we know the relevance and need for
performance testing let's look at the
types of performance testing
so there are six types of performance
testing namely load testing stress
testing volume testing capacity testing
reliability testing and scalability
testing
let's have a look at all the six types
of testing one after the other
so the first type is load testing load
testing is a type of performance testing
where the application is tested for its
performance on normal and peak usage
an application's performance is checked
concerning its response to the user
request and its availability to respond
consistently with an accepted endurance
on different user loads
here the main consideration is the
maximum load the application can hold
before the application starts behaving
abruptly
then another consideration is regarding
how much data the database can handle
before the system crashes the second
type of performance testing is stress
testing
stress testing is a type in which
different ways to break the system are
found that is how much load a system can
sustain
stress testing has an incremental
approach where the load is increased
gradually the test started with a load
for which the application has already
been tested then more load is added
slowly to stress the system
the point at which we start seeing
servers not responding to the request is
considered the breaking point
here the major considerations are the
maximum load to a system can sustain
before it breaks down then how is the
system broken down and how will the
system be able to recover once it has
crashed we also see in how many ways a
system can break and which are the weak
nodes that are to be kept in mind while
handling the unexpected load moving
forward the next type is volume testing
volume testing is the type where the
performance of the system is checked
with respect to the volume of the data
to execute a volume test a huge volume
of data is entered into the database
this test can be incremental or steady
test in the incremental test the volume
of the data is increased gradually
generally with the application usage the
database size grows and it is necessary
to test the application against a heavy
database if we consider an example let's
say there is a website of college having
small amounts of data to store initially
but after five to ten years the data
stored in the database of the website is
much more and has become huge
now comes the fourth type of performance
testing the capacity testing
so capacity testing is a type of testing
where the application is checked for its
capability to meet the business volumes
capacity testing is generally done for
future prospects
here the main concerns are if the
application would be able to support the
future load
if the environment is capable of
standing the upcoming increased loan and
what are the additional resources
required to make the environment capable
enough
capacity testing helps in determining
how many users or transactions of a
given web application is capable of
supporting and will perform well during
this testing resources such as processor
capacity
network bandwidth memory usage disk
capacity etc are considered and altered
to meet the goal
to consider an excellent example of
capacity testing we can see the case of
online banking moving forward the next
type of testing is the reliability
testing reliability testing is a type in
which the application is verified if the
application would be normal again after
an abnormal state
it estimates the time that the system
would take to return to its normal state
to understand the concept let's say
there is an online trading site that
experiences some failure and because of
which the users are not able to buy or
sell shares at a certain point of the
day but after a couple of hours they
were able to operate their shares and
the application became normal this is
when it can be said that the application
is reliable and can recover from its
abnormal state the last type of testing
is scalability testing scalability
testing is a type where the application
is determined if it would be able to
scale up whenever needed
the need for scaling up comes when there
is an increase in user load now when we
have learned the types of performance
testing we must learn the process of
performance testing
so the process of performance testing is
divided into eight parts that is
requirement gathering selection of tools
performance test plan performance test
development performance test modeling
execution of test test result analysis
report now let's have a look at all of
these processes one after the other the
first step in the process is requirement
gathering the requirements are
identified and gathered from the clients
by the performance team this includes
getting information on the application's
architecture technologies database used
intended users functionality application
usage test requirement hardware and
software requirements etc the second
step in the process is selection of
tools
after the previous step poc or proof of
concept is done with the available tools
the proof of concept is a sort of
demonstration of real-time activity but
in a limited sense
the list of available tools depends on
the tools cost the protocol that the
application is using the technologies
used to build the application the number
of users we were simulating for the test
etc now the third step the third step is
the performance test plan in reference
to the above two steps test planning and
designing are conducted the process of
test planning involves information on
how the performance test is going to
take place like the test environment
workload hardware etc moving forward the
fourth step is performance test
development in this step the use cases
for the identified functionalities are
created
these use cases are shared with the
client for their approval
once the clients approve the use case
the script development begins these
scripts are validated against several
different users and parallel to script
creation the performance team sets up
the test environment the performance
team also takes care of metadata through
scripts if the client does not take up
that activity so the next step is
performance test modeling
performance load model is created for
the test execution
this step aims to validate whether the
given performance metrics are achieved
during the test or not then the sixth
step is execution of tests the scenario
is designed according to the load model
in controller or performance center
initially the tests are not executed
with maximum users that are in the load
model the test execution is done in
incremental order let's say there are
thousand users then the scenario will
begin testing from 100 then go to 250
then 350 and so on it will gradually
increase and go up to 1000 users
the next step is the seventh step in our
process
that is the test result analysis
the test results are the most important
deliverable for the performance tester
this is where we can prove the return on
investment and productivity that a
performance testing effort can provide
what makes the result analysis process
more effective is that we must have a
unique and meaningful name for every
test result which will help us
understand the test purpose in the test
summary certain things must be included
like the reason for failure how the
performance of the application changes
regarding the previous runs it is also a
good practice to make a result summary
after each test run so that the analysis
results are not compiled every single
time the results are referred
then the final and the last step in
performance testing process is the
report the test results should be
simplified so that conclusion is clearer
and should not create any derivation
the development team needs more
information on analysis comparison of
results and details of how the results
were obtained the test report is
considered to be good if it's brief
descriptive and to the point
now that we know the performance testing
the next important topic to discuss is
the understanding of performance testing
metrics
the first is processor usage which
refers to the amount of time the
processor spends executing the non-idle
threads second metric is memory usage
memory use is the amount of physical
memory available to the processor on a
computer system the third metric is this
time which is the amount of time the
disk is busy in executing read or write
request the fourth metric is the
bandwidth that shows the bits per second
used by a network interface moving
forward the next metric is the private
bytes it is the number of bytes a
process has allocated that can be shared
amongst the other processes these are
used to measure memory leaks and usage
then comes the committed memory this is
the amount of virtual memory used then
the next metric we have is the response
time it is the time between when the
user enters a request to time to the
first character of the response is
received
next metric is the throughput it is the
rate at which a computer or a network
receives requests per second moving
forward the next metric is the hit
ratios the hit ratios are concerned with
the number of sql statements that are
handled by case to data instead of
expensive input output operations
and the last metric in our list is the
top weights these are monitored to
determine what wait times can be cut
down to make the data retrieval faster
from memory apart from this some metrics
like the rollback segment garbage
collection thread counts heads per
second cpu interruption per second disk
q length etc now when we know almost
everything that is needed regarding
performance testing it is very important
to know the tools that make performance
testing possible here are the top 5
performance testing tools in the market
today the first tool we have is the load
runner or hp load runner as the name
suggests the load runner is great when
it comes to handling a large amount of
users for testing the second tool in our
list is webload web load is one of the
best testing tools for stress and load
testing the next tool in our list is
load ui load ui is a great testing tool
to map the scalability and speed of the
target product the fourth tool in our
list is new load it is one of the
fastest testing tools with a speed of
around 10 times the traditional testing
tools that are integrated seamlessly
into our existing software with a wide
array of tests the last tool in our list
is the apache j meter apache j meter is
one of the best and most used testing
tools in the market right now it is
highly capable of creating a large
number of virtual users working on web
server moving forward we shall talk
about jmeter and understand why jmeter
is preferred over all the other
performance testing tools in the market
so moving forward let's see what jmeter
is
j meter or apache meter is an open
source software that is 100 pure java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance jmeter is originally
designed for testing web applications
but has since expanded to other test
functions to understand the concept of
jmeter let us assume that someday your
team leads tell you to perform
performance testing on some website like
facebook or google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing comes to
your mind do you think it's practically
possible to arrange 100 people with
computers and access to internet and
accessing the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for 10 000 users this is when a
need for software like jmeter arises so
what jmeter does is it actually
simulates
it will simulate the real user's
behavior and perform load tests on
server group of servers network or
object now let's have a look at some
reasons why geometer is used for load
testing we have divided these reasons
into six parts
the first one is it's free of cost
second one is performance testing of
applications next one platform
independent the fourth one is
customizable fifth is recording and
playback and finally sixth is the
community support let's see all of these
one after the other the first reason we
have as free of cost one of the main
deciding factors in any software is its
cost normally a software can range from
high as 6 to 7 figures per license here
jmeter is free of cost very intuitive
and has all the possibilities you need
to automate your work then the second
reason is performance testing of
applications the application is used to
perform performance testing on different
types of applications like web
applications web services ldap database
and shell scripts jmeter can conduct
load and performance tests for many
different servers and server types web
http and https database via jdbc ldap
and jms the third reason is
platform independence
jmeter is written and developed using
java to run on any environment or
workstation that accepts java virtual
machine for example windows linux mac
etc the next reason we have is that the
jmeter is customizable since jmeter is
an open source application it enables
developers to customize
whenever needed jmeter has a
comprehensive and user-friendly
graphical user interface
parameters are easy to define and
understand scripting is simpler and
clearer and adding and defining elements
as more intuitive also one screen shows
everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis
the samplers are highly customizable
when determining which request to be
sent to the host however samplers don't
enable full control of test actions
moving forward the following reason is
recording and playback
the application provides record and
playback options enabled with the drag
and drop feature making the application
faster and easier the next and the last
reason on our list is incredible
community support jmeter is an open
source tool with a brilliant community
that keeps adding features and supports
users who run into issues and problems
this ensures new users always have
someone to answer their questions and
long time users can improve their
abilities on gmeter also having an open
source tool ensures that it keeps
getting better and is always in line
with users needs and requirements
finally let's have a look into the demo
that shows the working of jmeter
so the first step is we shall go to the
apache jmeter folder
in that folder go inside the bin folder
and select the
jmeter.pat file double click on this
file
this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the test
plan elements are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
i have renamed this test plan as
performance testing
now the first step is to add thread
group
right click on the performance testing
go to add
then go to thread or users
and select thread group
let's name this as perform
here the thread group refers to the used
or created users or needed to run this
test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it the way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want then there is a ramp up period
in seconds option that states the time
gap between the users hits third there
is a loop count where you can choose how
many times the test will run for the
number of users you can also choose the
test to run in finite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the test end
time let's make the number of threads to
b2 and let's make the loop count to be
100
the next step is to add an http request
for that right click on the thread group
go to add option and go to the sampler
option in the menu that appears select
the http request option here on the
screen there is a server name or ipbox
we have to give the server name or the
ip in that let's pick up a website and
place the link in the box we shall use
the simply learns website here go to
simply learn's website and copy the url
from here then come back to the jmeter
window and paste it onto the server name
box keep in mind we don't need to give
the http or https since these are
protocols which will come in the other
box and
they will be automatically taken in the
http request case
then in the path dialog box we will
leave the forward slash there since we
have to access the root page
and let's rename this http request as
simple now
to get results we shall add listeners
listeners are something that are used to
provide the outputs of a load test there
are different types of listeners present
in jmeter and many may be added using
plugins we will use three different
listeners here to have an idea about the
representation that the jmeter provides
for that right click on the thread group
then go to the ad select listener option
and go to the view results entry option
then again right click on the listener
option and choose graph results
and for the third listener again right
click and select the view results in the
table option
now it's time to run the test
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
on the green button here to run second
is you can go to the run option and
choose the run the test and the third
way you can right click on the first
jmeter and choose to run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
first we will have to save this j meter
test and then we shall go on to check
the results of the test
here in the view results tree we can see
the test being run
the same in the case of graph results we
can see the throughput option then we
can also see the time the test has been
executing since we had put the threads
to 2 and the loop count to 100 so the
test will run for a while
we can check the view results in the
table we can see different performance
testing metrics on the screen you can
see the thread name label sample time
per second bytes sort bytes and the
latency and in the tree option when we
click on the test we can see a lot of
information appearing on the screen
these are again several performance
testing metrics and in the graph results
we can see the graph coming up on the
screen now which represents the test
taking place with respect to the ip
address thread and loop counts so what
jmeter exactly does is creates a request
and sends it to the server once it
receives the service response it
collects them and visualizes those
details in a chart or graph after that
it processes the service response and
finally it generates the test results in
several formats such as text xml json so
that the tester can analyze the data
let's get started with what is load
testing
load testing is a type of performance
testing that determines an application's
behavior when a large number of users
access the application together here
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability and reliability
of the software application under a
particular workload the testing
determines a system's performance
according to real-life conditions
to give you a better idea let's say you
have a printer so you want to test a
printer by transferring large number of
documents for printing or test a mail
server with thousands of concurrent
users or to test a word processor by
making a change in a large volume of
data this helps to know whether the
existing infrastructure is capable of
running the application or not
load testing checks how much load can a
system handle the testing identifies the
limitations due to hardware like cpu
maximization network bottleneck memory
limitation etc and it also identifies
the issues in software configurations
such as web server application server
database server etc
it helps to identify the maximum
operating capability of an application
and checks the performance of the
application under different load
conditions of system components and
database components load testing is
conducted to determine the number of
concurrent users that an application can
support without performance
deterioration the response time of each
transaction of an application and the
network delay between the client request
and server response are also checked
load testing proves itself very
significant when it comes to data mining
user demands and satisfaction
several tools make load testing possible
such as apache geometer web load load ui
load runner neo load load ninja etc
here in this session
we shall be using j meter for load
testing
so j meter or apache geometer is open
source software that is 100 pure java
application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance
performance testing means testing a web
application against heavy load multiple
and concurrent user traffic it was
originally designed for testing web
applications but has since expanded to
other test functions to simplify let us
assume that someday your team leads tell
you to perform performance testing for
some websites like yahoo.com or
google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing that comes
to your mind do you think it's
practically possible to arrange 100
people with 100 computers and access the
internet and accessing the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for 1000 or 10 000 users
this is when we need a software like
jmeter
so what jmeter does is it simulates it
will simulate real user behaviors and
perform load testing on a server group
of servers network or object next let's
have a look at some reasons why jmeter
is used for load testing
we have divided these reasons into six
parts
it is free of cost performance testing
of applications
platform independent customizable
recording and playback and community
support
now let's see all of these one after the
other the first one free of cost one of
the main deciding factors in any
software is its cost normally a software
can range from high as six to seven
figures per license here jmeter is free
of cost very intuitive and has all the
possibilities you need to automate your
work
the next one is performance testing of
applications
the application is used to perform
performance testing on different
applications like web applications web
servers ldap database and shell scripts
jmeter can conduct load and performance
tests for many different server types
like web http and https database via
jdbc ldap and jms
the third important reason is it's
platform independent in nature jmeter is
written and developed using java
programming language to run on any
environment or workstation that accepts
a java virtual machine for example
windows linux mac etc
the next reason we have is jmeter is
highly customizable since jmeter is an
open source application it enables
developers to customize it whenever
needed jmeter has a comprehensive and
user graphical user interface parameters
are easy to define and understand
scripting is simpler and cleaner and
adding and defining elements is more
intuitive
also one screen shows you everything you
need the script the scenario and the
analysis the samplers are highly
customizable when determining which
request is to be sent to a host however
samplers don't enable full control of
test actions
moving forward the following reason is
recording and playback the application
provides record and playback options
enabled with the drag and drop features
making the application faster and easier
the next and the last reason in our list
is incredible community support jmeter
is an open source tool with a brilliant
community that keeps adding features and
supports users who run into issues and
problems
this ensures new users always have
someone to answer their questions and
long time users can improve their
abilities on jmeter
also having an open source tool ensures
it keeps
getting better and always in line with
users needs and requirements now after
we know about jmeter and the reasons to
use shear meter let's understand the
process to perform load testing with a
hands-on demo the only thing that is
kept in mind before this demo is we must
have a fully functional j meter on our
system and by now we know that j meter
can be used in any operating system like
linux windows mac os and ubuntu in this
demo we shall look into both the
graphical user and non-graphical user
interface mode of load testing
so the first step is we shall go to the
apache geometer folder in that folder go
inside the bin folder and select the
jmeter.pad file double click on this
file this might take a while and then
the jmeter window will open on the
screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side the elements
of the test plan are added and on the
right side all the configurations of the
element that are added as we are on the
test plan element we can see the
configurations of the scene here the
test plan is like a place or a container
where all the elements we will use to
perform this test will be stored all the
requests the listeners and everything
will be stored here so the first step is
to add listeners for that go to test
plan right click on the test plan go to
add then go to threads users and select
a thread group the test group refers to
the users that are used or created or
needed to run this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it the way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want then there is a ramp up period
in seconds option that states the time
gap between the user's hits then the
third one there is a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
also choose the test to run in finite
times there is also a scheduler here to
help you schedule the start time and the
test and time for now let's leave
everything to be only one
the next step is to add the http request
for that right click on the thread group
and go to the option and go to the
sampler option
and go to the http request option here
on the screen there is a server name or
ipbox we have to give the server name or
the ip in that let's pick a website and
place the link in that box we shall use
the simply learns website here go to
simply learns website and copy the url
from there
now we have copied the simply learns url
now let's come back to the jmeter window
and paste it in the server name box keep
in mind that we don't need to give up
the http or https since these are
protocols which will come in the other
box and they will be automatically taken
in the http request case
so this is what i was talking about
now let's rename this name as simply
moving forward let's create one more
http request
for that again right click on the thread
group select samplers and select http
requests and go to simply learns website
again and there we have the resource
link go to that link and copy the url
then place that url in the server or ip
address box
we shall remove the http from that link
and add from the end cut the resource
part and paste it in the path box there
here we will rename the http request as
resources
moving forward to increase a load a
little bit more we shall use one more
http
so this time we shall add one more http
request again right click on the threads
group go to the samples option and
select the http request option again to
add one more link to the server and ip
address go to simply lens website go to
the corporate training link now copy the
url and go back to the jmeter window and
paste that url in the ip box
now cut the corporate training part from
the link and paste it to the other path
box
we shall again rename this http request
box as corporate now let's save this
file
in the save dialog box let's name it as
load testing dot jmx
now to get the results we shall add
listeners listeners are something that
is used to provide the outputs of the
load test there are different types of
listeners present in geometer and many
may be added using plugins the listener
we will use here is the tree as it is
comparatively easy to interpret for that
right click on the thread group then go
to add select listener option and we go
for the view results in three option
now it's time to run the test and check
the load for running the test there are
three simple ways first you can simply
click on the green button here to run
second is you can go to the run option
and choose the run test and the third is
the way you can right click on first
geometer and then choose run let's
simply choose the green button and run
the test after we run the test we shall
go to the check the results of the test
in the view results entry section we can
see the green symbol that states the
test has successfully completed since we
had left all the values to be one in the
beginning that's why there is just one
test for each http request now let's
increase the load and let's change some
numbers let's make the number of threads
to be 10 ramp up the periods to be 2 and
the loop count to be 10.
now let's run the test again with the
green button after running the test we
shall see the results in the tree and
see the testing being performed since we
have increased the number of users and
ramp up the periods and the loop count
we can see the test being performed
accordingly since the loop count now was
10 for each user the test will run 10
times so here on the screen we can see
the time taken and the number of tests
being performed on the status of each
hit onto the website this is how you
perform load testing in graphical user
mode now perform the same test in
non-graphical user mode we shall remove
the listener so let's remove the view
results in tree
after this we will go to the command
prompt and then in the command prompt we
shall put the pin folder path in the
apache geometer folder let's go to the
bin folder and copy the location from
here now paste the path in the command
prompt and execute it
once that is done the next step is to
put the command prompt for jmeter load
testing this command has got three parts
the first part is the hyphen n hyphen t
and hyphen l here the hyphen n
represents the non graphical user
interface mode hyphen t is used to
specify the location of the
test script hyphen l is used to specify
the location of our output result now go
to the location where our jmx file is
stored let's search for the
loadtesting.jmx file
copy the path and paste it in the
command prompt hyphen t
in the link that we paste towards the
end make sure that you add the name of
the file with dot gmx
now go back to the folder and make a dot
csv file make an excel spreadsheet and
rename it with dot csv extension
now copy this path and go back to the
command prompt and paste it after the
hyphen l in the path don't forget to add
the name of the csv file towards the end
then execute the command and wait for
the command to end
after the command is successfully run
you can see that the tree is
successfully created and towards the end
of that execution you can see that the
message is the end of the run
now you can go back to the folder and
open the loadtesting.csv file in that
file you can see the entire test result
has been generated
this shows that the command has been
successfully executed and the
load testing is successful in the
non-graphical mode without any errors
this is what we had in this demo we saw
the load testing in graphical user
interface and non-graphic user interface
mode
to have a better picture we use
dashboards dashboards include several
graphs that explain the working of the
website link we use in the http request
the dashboard generator is a modular
extension of jmeter
its default behavior is to read and
process samples from a csv file to
generate html files it generates the
report and at the end of the load test
are on demand the dashboard reports
provide metrics like the apd-ex or
application performance index
the dashboard also provides a statistics
table response time over time response
times percentiles over time active
threads over time and response times in
percentiles we shall learn about
dashboards and more in the forthcoming
videos in this video we learned how
critical is load testing in the software
testing process and how it ensures high
user satisfaction
a successful load testing will help to
release high quality software if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
let's get started with what an api is
we often come across this term while
reading any technical blog or magazine
an api or application programming
interface is a programming code that
enables data transmission between one
software product and another it is an
intermediary software allowing two
applications to communicate with each
other to understand api even better
let's take an example
for example you're booking a flight for
that you will begin with searching
flights online concerning your
destination departure return dates and
many more filters
to make all these choices you interact
with the airline's website and access
their database and see if there are any
seats available on those states and what
the costs might be
while you're doing all this from the
time to begin to the time you finish
booking your tickets you're doing that
with the help of an api
to simplify it even more it can be said
that whenever we use an application on
our mobile phone the application
connects to the internet and sends data
to the server the server then retrieves
the data interprets it performs
necessary actions and sends it back to
our phone
the application then interprets the data
and presents the information we wanted
in a readable way
this is what an api is so that means
each time we use an application like
facebook send an instant image check
weather on our phone or make some
specific choices while online shopping
we use an api now when we have a good
idea about what an api is let's look at
another major thing before going on to
the hands-on demo that is why we use
j-meter for api testing
apache g-meter is an open source
software and it is used to simulate
loads of various scenarios and output
performance data in several ways
including csv and xml files and graphs
we know that the apache geometer is 100
pure java application
so it is available on every os that
supports java 6 or later some of these
specific reasons what makes jmeter a
perfect fit for api testing are
jmeter enables fast api testing
it performs quick scope tests and
enables load and stress testing
then as we know it is an open source
tool and supports load testing and
stress testing
it has a lot of plugins and extensions j
meter can be used across several
platforms and can use various
programming languages
now we know about api basics and why we
use jmeter for its testing
it is the right time to see the process
of api testing in jmeter
to download jmeter you can go to the
apache jmeter website and download the
file to know the entire downloading
process and installing jmeter you can
check our jmeter download and
installation video in our jmeter
playlist
moving on i have my jmeter installed i
will go to the apache jmeter folder go
into the bin folder and open the batch
file
this might take a while and then the
geometer window will open on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections
on the left side all the elements of the
test plan are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the scene
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward right click on the
first j meter here and select the add
option
then in this option select the threads
option and then threads group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error or you can choose it the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user hits
third there is a loop count where you
can choose how many times the test will
run for the number of users
you can also choose the test to run in
finite times
there is also a scheduler here to help
you schedule the time for starting the
test and the time for ending the test
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
now for some sample apis go to your
browser and search for some sample rest
api for testing
in this we will go to the first link
that is
reqres.n
or requestresponse.n
we will create and run get
post
put and delete rest api request in
jmeter in the demo
here in this link we have all get
post put delete apis
so we shall choose the first link here
list users
here we have the link request
open this link in the new tab
then we have got the url for this api
copy this url and go to the j meter
window
then in the geometer window right click
thread group and go to add
in the box that appears select samplers
you can see all types of requests that
jmeter can work on we shall choose the
http request
here you will have to give the address
to some home pages or websites
here in the server name or ipbox we have
to give the server name or the ip so
here we shall paste the get api request
url
in the protocol box we shall put the
https
if in the url the protocol would have
been http then we would have left this
box empty
in the url we shall put the url link
remember that we do not put any slashes
here and that anything after the url
would be put in the path so we shall
remove the path from the url and put it
in the path box
then we shall take part from the
question mark and use it to give
parameters
since it is the get api we will have to
give parameters we will add the name in
the parameters and give the name as page
and value s2
in this http request drop down we can
see all the different types of http
requests that gmeter accepts for now we
shall leave it to be get since we are
using the get api and also let's name
this http request as get api
now when our http request is ready we
shall perform the test on it
to determine what the results of the
test will be we need to add some more
test elements we shall again right click
on the thread group go to the listener
options then in the box we can check the
different types of reports that jmeter
provides us
for now we shall select two of these
let's choose view results tree
and the view results in the table
now save the test
i will save the test with the name api
testing
and finally let's run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways
first you can simply click the green
button on the run
second you can go to this run option and
choose to run the test
and the third way is you can right click
on the first j meter and choose to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the result of the test
let's go to the view results stream
here we can see the green status that
shows the test was successful
and the view results in a table we can
see again the status is green
since we had put the number of threads
and loop to be one there is just one
entry in both the results now let's try
one more thing
we shall go to the thread group and
change the number of threads to be 10
and run the test again
after running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed and same happens in the
case of view results in table
now in the view results tree we can
click on a request and see different
information here we can see the sample
start load time latency error etc
same in the view results in table you
can see all such information in a
tabular format
you can also see the response data here
this is the same data as it was there
when we copied the url from the browser
you can furthermore check the response
headers and the request that was placed
now we are done with the get api request
let's add the second request that is the
post request
again add a http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group then come
back to the browser window and click on
the post api option
then
open the request url in the new window
then go to this window copy the url and
come back to the jmeter window
first let's rename this http request as
post api
then let's paste the url in the server
name or ipbox again let's put http in
the protocol box
address in the server or ip address box
and path in the path box
and in this http request drop down
select the post option this time
then let's go to the parameter part here
select the body data option
and we shall have to add body now
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
[Music]
come back to the jmeter window and paste
the body here
here you can check some advanced
settings also in case you need them
for now since this is just a demo we
shall keep it really simple
so let's run this
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output
then we shall save the test and run it
now you can see the two tests are here
since the thread count is one let's make
the thread count to be 10 again let's
see what happens
now when i run the test i can see the
test running a required number of times
that is 20 times again i can see
information about different requests
that include different parameters like
latency errors etc
now let's move on to our third api
request that is the put request
go back to the browser and click on put
request
open the request in the new tab
copy the url and come back to the jmeter
window
make a new http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this http request as
put api
then let's paste the url in the server
name
or ipbox
again let's put http in the protocol box
address the server or ip address box and
path in the path box
and in the http request drop down select
the put option this time
here also we shall have to add body data
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
coming back to jmeter window select the
body data option and we shall have to
add body now and paste the body here
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output make the
thread count to be 1 and then we shall
save the test and run it
now you can see the three tests here
since the thread count is 1 here by
clicking on the api request we can check
a lot of data like the response body and
response headers and same in the case of
view results in the table you can see
the data in a tabular format let's make
the thread count to be 10 and again see
what happens
now when i run the test i can see the
test running a required number of times
and here i can see information about
different requests
now let us add our last api request that
is the delete request
go back to the browser and click on the
delete request
open the request in the new tab copy the
url and come back to the jmeter window
make a new http request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this http request as
delete api
then let's paste the url in the server
name or ipbox again let's put http in
the protocol box address in the server
or ip address box and path in the path
box
and in this http request drop down
select the delete option this time
here there is nothing to be added in the
parameters section so let's go to the
two listeners and clear what all is
there
then save this test and run it
since we did not make the number of
threads one this time we can see the
test running n number of times
we can see the information of any api
request by just clicking on it
let's get started with what is script
recording record testing in j meter
helps testers to record and run their
activity against test targets it is a
type of automated testing but for
multiple users the test script is
designed to record such scenarios the
proxy server allows jmeter to watch and
record user activity while browsing web
applications with a normal web browser
when we talk about proxy it is a
component that is present between you
and the remote server let us say that
you want to record web browser
interactions when jmeter starts acting
like a proxy this is when jmeter script
recording is used script recording is
one of the advanced and impressive ways
to figure out and eliminate the
complexity of browser interactions and
software testing now when we know what
script recording is and how it is
relevant let's look into how to do it in
jmeter but before that let's check the
prerequisites of script recording in
jmeter there are three major
prerequisites first is having j meter
installed in your system the second
requirement is having java installed in
your system the third and final
requirement is having mozilla firefox in
your system now let us have a look at
the hands-on demo of how to perform
script recording in jmeter so the first
step is we shall go to the apache jmeter
folder in that folder we will go into
bin folder and then select the
jmeter.bat folder let us double click on
that this might take a while and then
the jmeter window will open on the
screen the home window is divided into
two sections on the left side all the
test plan elements are added and on the
right side all the configurations of the
elements are added as we are on the test
plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here you can
think of the test plan like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored all the requests all the
listeners and everything will be stored
here now the first step is to add thread
group so for that right click on the
thread group select add and from add go
to threads or users and in that select
thread group here the thread group
refers to the users it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period and second
option that states the time gap between
the user hits third there is a loop
count where you can choose how many
number of times the test will run for a
number of users you can also choose the
test to run for infinite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the tests
end time the next step is to add an http
request for that right click on the
thread group go to the add option and
now go to the sampler option select the
http request option here there is a
server name or ipbox we have to give the
server name or ip in that let us pick a
website and place the link in the box we
shall use the simply learns website here
go to simplylands website and copy the
url from here then come back to the
jmeter window and paste it in the server
name box keep in mind that we don't need
to give http or https since these are
protocols that will come in the other
box and they will be automatically taken
in the http request case then in the
path dialog box we will leave a forward
slash there since we have to access the
root page now the next step is to add
the http test script recorder for that
right click on the test plan then go to
non-test elements and select the http
test script recorder option the window
on the screen shows several options here
we can see the start option to begin the
test then there is a box that has the
port number you can make this number
whatever you like i'll put this number
as one two three four for now then let's
go back to the simply learns website and
go to the resources page then come back
to the jmeters window and rename the
recording controller as resources now
let us add another recording controller
so that jmeter works like a proxy with
the help of https test script recorder
then again go back to the resources page
that we just opened and scroll down a
little bit here we can see several
technologies and several other links in
those links you can select any one of
the links i will select digital
marketing here then go back to the
jmeter window and rename the recording
controller as digital marketing then
finally let's add a recording controller
for the home page and rename it as
simply learns home page so now we can
see that we have a thread group here
then there is a http request where we
have simply learn website in the server
name then there are three recording
controllers one for the resources the
second for digital marketing and a third
one for home page and last we have a
http test script recorder here i will
rearrange the recording controllers in
sequence putting the simply learns home
page controller on the top and then
placing the resources finally digital
marketing recording controller now let
us open mozilla firefox in our system go
to the general option here and scroll
down to the network settings in the
network settings option select settings
in the window that appears select the
manual proxy configuration here we shall
put the port number for now i will put
the port number as 1234 in this box
here in the http proxy we have localhost
and we have selected to use this proxy
for ftp and https and then click on ok
now go back to the apache jmeter folder
and now we shall use this apache jmeter
temporary root ca file which is a
security certificate file so coming back
to the mozilla firefox window go to the
options tab and in this tab i will type
certificates and here we shall select
view certificates in the window that
opens let us import the security
certificate from jmeter folder here we
shall select these two boxes so that the
proxy server can access the website that
we shall enter here in the browser and
then select ok coming back to the jmeter
window let us add some listeners to get
the results listeners are something that
are used to provide the outputs of a
test there are different types of
listeners present in geometer and many
may be added using plugins for adding
listeners right click on http test
script recorder for adding listeners
right click on the http test script
recorder then go to add option and then
go to listeners option and then add view
results tree now let us add one more
listener in the same way we shall add
view results entry now in the http test
script recorder in the target controller
option save the target controller here
in the drop down select the simply learn
homepage option as we will begin the
script recording for the home page
finally let's start the test by clicking
here click on ok now go back to the
mozilla browser and here let us open the
simply learns home page now come back to
the jmeter window go to the home page
recording controller you can see the
homepage controller has started as you
can see the homepage controller has
started recording the scripts that are
being performed these are the tasks that
are performed on the client side to the
server side now we can check both the
listeners that we have put to see what
all functions are working fine and what
all are not all the tasks from the time
that we have entered to simplylearn.com
in our browser are recorded in this
homepage controller to take the test
further go to the test script recorder
and stop the test now here in the target
controller select the second controller
that is the resources controller now
start the test again select ok go to
simply learns website select resources
after opening the resources link go back
to the jmeter window and now in the
resources controller you can see what
all events are recorded from the client
side to the server side once we click on
the resources link now again in the two
listeners you can check all the scripts
and tests are successful or have failed
now for our last recording controller go
back to the test script recorder and
stop the test now here in the target
controller select the third option that
is the digital marketing now here in the
target controller select the third
option that is digital marketing start
the test and select ok now get back to
the mozilla firefox window go to
resources go to digital marketing after
digital marketing link has opened go
back to the jmeter window and now in the
digital marketing controller you can see
what all events are recorded from the
client side to the server side once we
click on that link i guess this is
taking a while you can see all steps
coming under the recording controller
and then you can also see the two
listeners some of the tests are being
successful and some are not we can sum
this entire process as a way of
communicating between the server and the
client with a proxy server help in this
case the proxy server is rj meter that
is why it was able to record all the
steps that are happening while we were
performing any task this is how we can
perform the jmeter script testing in few
simple steps now when you are done with
the proxy server do not forget to go
back to your browser and change your
network settings back to normal that is
go to the settings select use system
proxy settings and that's how it is done
well with that we have come to an end of
this jmeter complete tutorial for
beginners i hope this session was
informative and interesting if you have
any queries regarding any of the topics
covered in the session or if you need
the code that is executed in this
particular tutorial then please feel
free to let us know in the comment
sections below our team of experts will
be happy to resolve all your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here